from the worldwide leader in sports love
following you on twitter and instagram
and of course his commentary on
espn is second to none day after baylor
waxes gonzaga for the national
championship
jay bill is here on the rich eisen show
how are you sir i'm doing great rich how
are you that wasn't even
i mean they they baylor had everyone at
hello last night huh
what it didn't remind you the super bowl
a little bit you know we we talked about
the offense of gonzaga kind of like we
talked about the chiefs and
you know how explosive they were a
beautiful offensive team to watch and
and uh and just like the chiefs gonzaga
got
bullied by baylor uh the way the
buccaneers bullied uh
kansas city i mean it was very similar
uh and look i think gonzaga is better
than they played
but uh but baylor was
just so strong in every facet of the
game their defense was great
they forced gonzaga further out on the
floor and made everything
extraordinarily difficult
um and look you can cut all you want if
you can't see the cutters it doesn't
matter
and uh and they couldn't see anybody and
couldn't hang on to the ball they
had the ball just taken from them and uh
and got pounded on the glass it was just
a
a fabulous performance by baylor
it sure was and uh it made me think that
anybody that could have snuck through or
didn't you know that
my alma mater or anybody no
no one was beating baylor in this
tournament this was their tournament to
have and
and they took it jay for sure yeah i
think that's probably
i think that's right i mean michigan was
compromised without isaiah livers
um look i i don't i don't believe that
baylor was
unbeatable uh just like i didn't think
that gonzaga was unbeatable
but you know it's funny we got exactly
what we wished for and that was
what we consider to be the two best
teams that had separated
from the pack all year long and that was
baylor and gonzaga and we thought
you know we thought that okay well
michigan uh
toward the end of the year they joined
that top tier and illinois had joined
that top tier
but no one had displaced either gonzaga
or
or baylor from from that and then we got
what we wanted and
and man you know baylor kind of said you
know one game seven game series whatever
you know we're gonna we're gonna take
the trophy home and i think in a seven
game series after watching that
you know i think a number of people were
saying well after that hellacious game
that baylor played against ucla
well what what what were they missing
that would have like
what did ucla take away from them that
they would have had
against that pressure that they faced
you know i i just don't i don't buy that
that somehow
you know their edge was gone and and
ucla took something out of them
um i don't believe that i i would look
more
upon that as an excuse for losing
interesting jay because they did seem to
be a step
slow you know they did seem to like that
the suggs reach in for the second foul
for instance that sort of stuff and
and and timmy did you know it looked
like we had like
low energy timmy last night certainly in
the first five 10 minutes so you don't
you don't you don't buy that saturday
night
uh either gave uh press clippings that
gonzaga believed
or or baylor um not that there
anybody needs extra motivation but they
sat there and watched
all of us fawn all over the instant
classic while
forgetting baylor even made the game you
don't think that was any factor
certainly in the first 10 minutes that
lingered for much of the 40
last night i really don't i really don't
i you know i i made this point the other
day i was ty
we had talked about this and somebody
had i i hark back to when i was a player
and we lost in the championship game and
and afterwards everybody said well you
know we played a really difficult
semi-final game it was going to versus
two
and it came down to the wire and
louisville you know had a cake walk
against lsu or something like that and
and i was going you know what we've won
a bunch of games when we were tired when
we played
you know at the acc tournament we played
three days and three days straight
against top top
ten competition and nobody ever said we
were tired when we won
they only say that when you lose and uh
so i've never bought that
uh i just don't i i'm not a believer in
that
and when you looked at what gonzaga was
trying to accomplish
and baylor took everything away from him
i don't think an extra night's sleep
would have made any difference
jay bellas here on the rich eisen show
can you put into perspective for those
watching and listening right now sir
uh what scott drew built and the odds
against which he built them this team
yeah i don't think i don't think baylor
fans like remembering this but
uh you know 16 17 years ago there was a
murder a player on player murder at
baylor
one player murdered another one and the
coach at the time dave bliss
uh came up with this ridiculous cover-up
not only to cover up ncaa violations but
to make it seem like
the player murdered with some sort of
drug issue drug deal or whatever
it was the most bizarre thing you'd ever
seen and when scott drew who was at
valparaiso at the time it had just taken
over for his father's head coach he
wasn't even there for a year if i
remember right as head coach
when he took the job i think a lot of us
myself included were like
are you crazy you know that's like
coming up in a rescue ship
alongside the titanic saying no i'll
captain this one
i got this um it just didn't seem to
make any sense
and he's not only built it into a
powerhouse it's a model program
and it's it's a program that's got a
great vibe you know anytime you're
around it it's got it
they've got a wonderful spirit to them
and
uh uh you know they recruit at the
highest level their players are all good
guys
uh like at gonzaga and other other
places
um so you know this isn't a uh you know
uh
they're not just on a good run here that
this is a program that has staying power
for the long term they you know heck
they could have won it last year
if we had a tournament there were other
teams that were right there with them
gonzaga kansas uh you know san diego
state
dayton some others florida state but uh
but this year it was them in gonzaga
uh the whole year and then you know over
the last what would you say quarter
century 30 years the drew family
has has quite a stamp on on this
tournament
and this sport and march madness from
homer drew
drawn up the play for bryce drew valpo
one of the greatest shots in the
in the history of the first weekend of
the ncaa tournament and upsets that we
talk about
for years to come and now here's scott
uh
turning baylor into national champions
after what you just described
first national champion in the state of
texas and men's basketball since
the glory road don haskins 1966 texas
western team
i mean this is serious history that
they're writing as a family
wouldn't you say yeah i think so
oh and and they're becoming uh you know
and bryce made the tournament this year
at grand canyon he was that he had taken
the job at uh
at vanderbilt and got beat you know
gotten fired there after getting beat so
much
in display but then he turns around
takes grand canyon to the tournament
uh which is extraordinary so for that
family to have accomplished all that and
uh
and i think all of them uh have had
their success individually as well as as
together
uh it's really a nice story they're
they're really nice people
that that's the the main thing i mean
you know scott has always got time for
other people he's always putting others
first
and thinking about their uh you know
their well-being and
you know anytime you're there to do a
game uh you know he's always calling you
hey you need anything and
it's like yeah that doesn't happen very
often actually we're chasing the head
coach around
and he's calling you to say hey you need
anything that's a pretty good deal jay
bill is here on the rich eisen show
couple of other
items uh up for bids to use the uh the
phrase that pays
um hubert davis named the new head coach
uh at north carolina succeeding roy
williams there i know you know hubert
uh i saw your you tweeted out that old
sports center
uh or old espn commercial with you and
he back in the day what do you think of
the hire
i think it's fantastic um
you know hubert is not only a good
friend uh he's one of the best
basketball people i've ever known
and you know he played at north carolina
for dean smith he played in the nba for
a dozen years for some of the best
coaches uh
that the nba has had and then he's been
with roy williams the last nine years
and certainly you have to think he
learned a lot from me on college game
day for seven years he's not working
alongside this
you know that's got to be part of the
equation for his basketball college
he's about as nice a person as i've ever
met in my life and
and he he would put me to shame as a
father and a husband and all that
and uh and so i think it's a it's the
perfect fit
for a great program you know he's the
right guy at the right time i think and
now here we go again i mean obviously
mike woodson
in indiana hubert davis in north
carolina
you know obviously patrick ewing back at
georgetown my
alma mater hiring juwon howard is this
is this the the new wave here is to is
to find a former player from your
from your uh from your school to to
restore
or keep something going i mean have we
seen something
jay what do you think certainly it yeah
it certainly makes the fans happy
uh especially at the beginning and
nothing's gonna make them happy if you
don't win
so they don't care what family you came
out of if you don't win
uh so that's the that's the baseline for
every every coach
no matter no matter what the higher but
it we've seen that as a trend where
uh everybody says family now you know
it's not it's not you know
a teammate it's now now it's a brother
and uh so we've got these family you
know this sort of this family stuff
being being uh talked about a lot and
hiring within the family
even though it's funny rich you know
that the head of the family didn't come
from the family you know
the head of the family came from
somewhere else usually um
but i think it's all great like hubert
knows the place and and he was talking
with us yesterday i think it was on one
of the game day shows we had
about you know his his uncle walter
davis was an all-american for dean smith
at uh
at carolina and he said i've been in
love with north carolina since i was
four years old since i worked
first walked on the campus and he said
they didn't recruit me
and dean smith uh i think dean smith and
bill guthrie i think he said came into
his home
and and they didn't offer a scholarship
and uh hubert said all i want is an
opportunity you give me an opportunity
and i'll make the most of it
and dean smith called him back a couple
days later and says you know what yeah i
thought about what you said it made an
impact and i'm going to give you that
opportunity and he was an all-american
there
um you know it's really an extraordinary
love story uh between
uh uh a player you know and then
assistant coach
his family and uh and and his
institution
a few more minutes left with jay bilas
here on the rich eisen show okay
counselor
uh it looked like last wednesday
um let me get the case right ncaa
v alston um in the supreme court of the
united states it sure looked like you
know
the justices ran like a match-up zone on
the ncaa lawyers and confused the hell
out of him like it was a syracuse first
or second round game jay i mean
everything that i read
it made it seem like when uh
an opinion may in this case be issued in
may
that that change is coming
can you can you you know put in layman's
terms what happened what you think is
happening or what will happen here with
the ncaa
jay yeah well first rich i think change
is coming anyway
irrespective of what the supreme court
does but there's a case before the
supreme court now
it's it's called the alston case and the
case is really
about whether the ncaa can put caps
on educational expenses so it's not just
they can't just say all right you get
you get a scholarship and a stipend and
that's it
if a school wants to give a an athlete a
laptop
or something something like that that
goes toward education right now they
can't do that that would be an ncaa
violation so
that's what the case is about it's
chipping away
at the amateurism principle now what i
would tell you
is is trying to read the tea leaves they
would say or trying to predict what the
supreme court will do
or decide from oral argument is is
a fool's errand it's it's more difficult
than trying to pick this
you know trying to pick games in the
6018 bracket
but long-time observers of the court you
know not
not people that look at sports cases but
but are are sitting there
and going over long-time observers that
have covered this forever have said that
based on my experience this is not good
for the ncaa
this is not a good sign for them uh that
their arguments were
were beaten up pretty hard and so one of
the things that that happens is
or that can happen is a justice can have
a particular opinion
and then stress test that opinion by
asking questions that are opposite to
what they think
so so you you can't always rely on
what's asked as a forecast of what's
going to happen but
but i don't think it's going to be
favorable favorable to the ncaa
and the funny part rich was they asked
for this they're the ones that took this
case to the supreme court so if they
lose it
uh all you have to do is look to
indianapolis saying why did you do that
you you actually had some pretty good
case law on your side with the o'bannon
case
uh why would you why would you do that
um but they did it
and uh look i i think they're arguing a
house of cards frankly
but uh but they've they've received
deference from the courts over the years
but i think that deference is waning and
and i think the uh the supreme court
oral argument was a
a pretty good sign that that's the case
so then what happens i mean
does uh does the way that we we
we see business done uh change like are
players going to get paid or
name and likeness image and stuff like
that or what what do you got what do you
think it's going to
i think they're going to get name image
and like this coming forward
that this is going to open that up the
ncaa should have done it already
they could solve all of this by just
passing less restrictive rules and
allowing the players the same economic
rights as literally everyone else
like as you know as you know rich uh
non-athlete students get more
scholarships than than
athletes so so are we saying they're
paid
but yet they're not they're not
restricted in any way as to what they
can earn or accept from their school or
from anybody else in the free market
whatever
um so the idea that the schools get
together as a cartel and restrict
athletes i don't think it's sustainable
in the long term
i'm surprised it's lasted this long
frankly but the ncaa could have made
these rules and what we're seeing
is states are passing name image and
like us laws right now
and the reason they're doing it is
because california did it florida did it
and other states are afraid they're
going to be left behind and they're
going to be uh out of luck for
for recruiting and and that sort of i
think
uh makes the argument that this is what
competition looks like
that when when when uh there's
competition for player services
people are willing to pay and they're
willing to allow all this stuff
um they know what's the most important
thing
it's not it's not who has the best coach
it's who has the best players
now coaches are important but if you
don't have players you know you can have
the greatest coach ever
the greatest coach with bad players
loses and the worst coach with good
players
wins um you know you you have to have
good players
and uh and they're worth a lot more than
a scholarship and i think that's
becoming pretty clear to everybody
so put your experience of being a trial
lawyer and a
college basketball analyst all together
jay uh if you think uh the
the supreme court's gonna upset things
here what are they the 12 seed against
the five seed
uh ncaa or is it a 12-5 match up
what do you got it eight nine uh is
there a
umbc based on how long do they go here
based on the way yeah based on the way i
view view the law the antitrust law
and the way the ncla behaves and what i
heard out of the one-hour oral argument
i think the ncaa loses this case and i
think going forward they're going to
lose a lot more of them
now they may not lose every one but
they're not going to win them all either
they used to win them all
because the the courts used to used to
give them an unbelievable amount of
deference but
i think they see now there's a
multi-billion dollar business how can
you claim somehow
that uh that this is this is amateur um
they see through it it's it's so obvious
and it's the one area where the ncaa has
never evolved
they've never they've never budged an
inch on athletes
but but man you tell them hey you can
make a billion dollars if you have a
playoff even though
they college football playoff even
though they said for years well we can't
do it it's impossible here are all the
reasons why
uh billion dollars oh okay we got one
the next year
uh you know it's ludicrous to suggest
that we can't do name image like this of
course we can
jay you're the best great run great
season thanks for the calls let's do it
again very shortly
you take care looking forward to it
brother thank you
right back at you jay bilas at jay
billis at realdealjbills right
on twitter and instagram hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here